Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
L’ARN messager,
voilà quelque chose dont peu d’entre nous
avaient entendu parler il y a un an.
Puis avec l’arrivée des vaccins
contre le Covid-19,
tout le monde a découvert cette molécule
et la technologie associée.
Un des arguments qui sont avancés
contre les vaccins ARN-messager,
c’est qu’ils ont été découverts trop vite,
mis au point trop vite.
Mais je ne vais pas tourner autour du pot.
Ces personnes ont tout faux.
Tout faux, parce que,
au sein de mon laboratoire,
nous travaillons sur cette technologie
depuis déjà quinze ans.
Aujourd’hui, je vais vous expliquer
que cette technologie a été mise au point
pendant des décennies de recherche.
Je vais également vous expliquer
que cette technologie
est maîtrisée et sûre.
Et je vais aussi vous montrer
qu’effectivement,
elle va nous donner de l’espoir
pour beaucoup, beaucoup de maladies.
Nous avons tous de l’ARN-messager dans
les cellules qui composent notre corps.
Cet ARN-messager,
je pense que vous l’avez entendu,
c’est une copie du gène
localisé sur les chromosomes
qui se trouvent dans nos noyaux.
Le noyau des cellules qui est
une véritable forteresse.
Ces ARN-messagers sont utilisés par
la cellule pour produire les molécules
dont elle a besoin pour fonctionner.
Vous allez voir tout à l’heure
à quoi ça va nous servir
pour soigner d’autres maladies.
Alors, pour comprendre cet ARN-messager,
j’insisterai sur trois points importants.
Le premier point, c’est que tout d’abord,
cet ARN-messager ne s’exprime
que pendant 2 à 3 jours.
Ce n’est pas très long,
mais cette durée,
qui n’est que de 2 à 3 jours,
est suffisante pour justement induire la
stimulation de notre système immunitaire.
En plus, cette courte durée
est très importante
parce qu’il n’y aura pas
de modification de nos cellules
grâce à cet ARN-messager
qui se trouve dans le vaccin.
Le deuxième point important
est que quand l’ARN-messager
qui se trouve dans le vaccin,
arrive dans nos cellules,
il ne peut pas re-rentrer dans le noyau.
L’ARN-messager ne peut donc pas
modifier un ou deux gènes
en rentrant dans ce noyau.
Aucune donnée scientifique jusqu’à
ce jour montre que ceci est possible.
En effet, c’est vraiment très important
que notre ADN soit bien protégé
pour que nos gènes ne puissent pas
être modifiés.
Un troisième point important,
c’est que cet ARN-messager
a été découvert il y a longtemps.
60 ans.
Et vous savez grâce à qui ?
À deux de nos prix Nobel français
qui sont allés aux États-Unis
pour travailler avec des collègues là-bas.
C’est François Gros
et François Jacob, en 1961.
Ça ne date pas d'hier.
C'est vraiment il y a très longtemps.
Il a fallu 25 ans pour que la technologie
puisse être mature
afin de l’utiliser à des fins vaccinales.
Mais pas quelques mois,
comme le prétendent certains
qui, hélas, s’autoproclament experts
en lisant des posts
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Alors vous allez me dire :
« Mais pourquoi 25 ans,
si c’est vraiment efficace ? »
Eh bien, 25 ans, messieurs, dames,
parce qu’il a fallu résoudre
plusieurs problèmes.
Le premier de ces problèmes,
c’est tout simplement
la fragilité de cet ARN-messager.
Je vous en ai parlé.
Pour pouvoir l’utiliser
et pour qu’il ait une efficacité,
il faut l’envelopper, le protéger.
Savez-vous qu’en 1993,
des chercheurs français,
l’équipe du professeur Pierre Meulien,
de l’Institut Pasteur Mérieux,
a déjà eu cette idée clé d’utiliser
un vaccin ARN-messager contre la grippe ?
On n'en parle pas beaucoup.
En fait, leur essai n’a pas pu aboutir,
tout simplement parce que
la technologie n’était pas mature.
Mais j’en parle aujourd’hui parce
qu’il faut quand même reconnaître
le travail pionnier
de ces chercheurs français.
Le deuxième problème
qu’il a fallu résoudre,
c’est la faible production de protéines
à partir de l’ARN-messager synthétique.
J’insiste, synthétique parce qu’en fait,
c’est produit à l’extérieur de la cellule,
synthétique.
Ce n’est qu’en 1998,
que deux professeurs américains
qui sont actuellement mondialement connus,
Katalin Karikó et Drew Weissman
de l’Université de Pennsylvanie,
ont découvert que l’ARN-messager
des microbes est complètement différent
de l’ARN-messagers qui se trouve
dans les mammifères, dans l’homme.
Saviez-vous que nos cellules arrivent
à détecter l’ARN-messager étranger
et activent des systèmes
qui entraînent leur destruction ?
Karikó et Weismann comprennent alors
qu’il va falloir faire en sorte que
l’ARN-messager synthétique ressemble
à l’ARN-messager
qui se trouve dans nos cellules.
Et en 2015, ils montrent qu’effectivement,
si on retouche cet ARN-messager
synthétique
en lui donnant des signes particuliers
similaires à ceux qu’on trouve
sur nos ARN-messagers naturels,
ces ARN-là produisent plus de protéines
et ne sont évidemment pas détectés,
ou très largement moins détectés
par les systèmes de dégradation
de nos cellules.
Ils ont déposé un brevet sur cette
technologie de production d’ARN-messager,
on va appeler ça inoffensif :
peu détecté par nos cellules.
Cette technologie est utilisée
à l’heure actuelle
dans les vaccins contre le Covid-19.
Alors, je pense que
toutes ces données
dont je viens de vous parler montrent
que ce n’est pas un complot mondial
qui a fait qu’on a fabriqué vite
ces ARN-messagers,
mais c’est vraiment le travail
acharné pendant des décennies
de plusieurs chercheurs.
Et quand on voit ce qui se passe
aujourd’hui,
on peut dire quand même que
c’est une grande victoire pour l’humanité.
Cette victoire, en fait, est possible
parce qu’il y a des éléments clés.
Le premier élément clé que je voudrais
partager avec vous,
c'est la méthode scientifique.
Cette méthode scientifique consiste
à émettre des hypothèses,
faire des expérimentations,
obtenir des données qui sont observables,
qu’on utilise après pour
faire progresser nos connaissances.
Le deuxième élément clé,
qui me tient beaucoup à cœur,
c’est l’interaction
entre plusieurs disciplines.
On a pu fabriquer ce vaccin à ARN-messager
parce qu’il y a eu trois domaines
qui ont été en interaction permanente :
la biologie, l’immunologie,
pour le système de défense immunitaire,
mais aussi la nano-médecine
pour justement l’encapsulation.
Bien évidemment, c’est également
l’interaction de différents chercheurs
à travers le monde.
Ces chercheurs ont partagé des méthodes
qui sont connues,
qui sont en fait robustes,
et c’est ça qui nous a permis d’aller
vers la fabrication des ARN-messagers.
Et là, on voit tout de suite
la dimension collective
du travail scientifique
que j’aimerais vraiment
partager avec vous.
Alors, le troisième élément clé est
bien évidemment, c’est le temps,
la patience, mais également la passion.
C’est le travail acharné pendant longtemps
de pionniers qui ont travaillé
effectivement dans l’ombre,
pour justement [défricher] une terra
incognita de la biologie,
à un moment où beaucoup de gens pensent
que c’était complètement inutile
ou même que c’était trop risqué.
Alors, une question reste.
Vous allez me dire : «Comment ça se fait
que nous avons fabriqué aussi vite
ces vaccins à ARN-messager ?»
Eh bien, laissez-moi vous expliquer
cela par une analogie.
Imaginons que vous vouliez faire la copie
de la clé de votre porte d’entrée.
Vous pouvez le faire vous-même,
vous décidez de faire vous-même,
sans savoir-faire, en tout cas,
c’est mon cas,
sans machines, sans matières premières.
Eh bien, on va prendre beaucoup de temps.
Si ça se trouve, on n’y arrivera jamais.
Mais si vous allez voir un spécialiste,
il va avoir les machines, le savoir-faire,
mais aussi les matières premières.
Il va vous faire ça en quelques minutes.
Eh bien, les sociétés de biotechnologies
qui ont décidé de fabriquer ce vaccin,
elles savaient,
il y a une matière première,
le savoir-faire et les machines.
Mais il leur manquait quelque chose :
c’était l’original.
Et pour cette époque du Covid-19,
eh bien, en fait, c’est le gène qui code
pour la protéine Spike -
vous en avez sûrement entendu parler -
c’est la clé que le virus utilise
pour infecter nos cellules.
Lorsque cette pandémie a été avérée,
le 12 janvier 2020, les collègues chinois
ont publié la séquence totale
du virus SARS-CoV2,
responsable de ce Covid-19.
Et dans ce séquençage,
il y avait le gène
qui code pour la protéine Spike.
Et savez-vous qu’en 18 semaines seulement,
les sociétés de biotechnologie
ont pu fabriquer
les ARN-messagers qui codent
cette protéine Spike.
Tout ceci, c’est tout simplement le fruit
de savoir-faire du travail
de décennies de recherche.
Ce n’est ni un complot,
ce n’est ni de la magie,
mais c’est vraiment la récolte de travail
qui a été effectué
pendant tout ce temps-là.
Alors, ces vaccins ont une efficacité
très élevée :
95 %, un taux à 95 %,
un taux qui est rarement atteint
pour des vaccins classiques.
Eh bien, ceci nous souffle de l’espoir
pour justement fabriquer des vaccins
contre des maladies infectieuses mortelles
dont aucun vaccin n’a pu aboutir
jusqu’à maintenant.
En septembre 2021,
la société Moderna, une de ces sociétés
biotechs, a lancé un essai clinique
de ce vaccin à ARN-messager contre HIV,
vous savez, le virus responsable du SIDA.
Il y a eu aussi des résultats
très prometteurs
qui ont été publiés sur un vaccin
ARN-messager contre le plasmodium,
l’agent pathogène responsable
du paludisme,
qui, malheureusement, affecte un grand
nombre de populations dans le monde -
on n’en parle pas souvent -
avec un taux de mortalité très élevé.
Mais ces ARN-messagers peuvent
aussi être utilisés
pour lutter contre le cancer,
à des fins thérapeutiques.
C'est ce que j'essaye de faire
dans mon laboratoire.
Qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?
Savez-vous que
sur les cellules cancéreuses,
il existe des molécules qui sont modifiées
appelées antigènes tumoraux ?
On peut donc fabriquer des ARN-messagers
contre ces antigènes tumoraux
pour que justement notre système
immunitaire puisse les détecter
et éradiquer ces cellules cancéreuses.
Mais plus encore,
on peut utiliser les ARN-messagers
pour produire des molécules
dont nous savons
qu’elles sont capables de stimuler
ou d’amplifier le système immunitaire.
Et là encore, on va pouvoir les combiner
pour éradiquer différents types de cancer.
Enfin, cet ARN-messager
peut aussi être utilisé
dans la médecine régénératrice.
Vous savez, cette médecine qui consiste
à réparer des organes
et des tissus qui sont abîmés.
Là encore, on va produire
des ARN-messagers
qui vont coder
des molécules que l’on connaît
et qui sont capables de stimuler
la réparation de ces tissus abîmés.
Plus encore, on peut utiliser
ces ARN-messagers pour faire
ce qu’on appelle la reprogrammation
cellulaire des cellules adultes.
Ça consiste en quoi ?
On va récupérer les cellules
à partir de la peau,
on va les dédifférencier pour produire
des cellules souches
afin de repeupler les organes
qui sont abîmés ou détériorés.
Donc, vous voyez tout de suite
l'importance de ce type de thérapie.
Le dernier exemple
dont j’aimerais vous parler,
c’est l’utilisation de cet ARN-messagers
dans le cas des maladies auto-immunes.
Il y en a beaucoup.
Ces maladies où nos propres corps,
malheureusement, produisent des anticorps
dirigés contre nos propres cellules
et qui les détruisent.
C’est le cas des scléroses multiples.
On va pouvoir fabriquer
des ARN-messagers pour justement inhiber
la création de ces auto-anticorps -
on les appelle comme ça -
afin qu’ils ne détruisent pas
nos propres cellules.
Ça s'appelle induire une tolérance.
Alors, messieurs-dames, je voudrais juste
vous rappeler pour conclure
le rôle vital
de cette recherche scientifique
qui nous a permis de sortir
de cette crise sanitaire historique.
Alors, aux chercheurs du monde entier
qui travaillent pour améliorer nos vies,
à ceux qui les soutiennent,
parce qu’ils en ont besoin,
mais aussi à vous pour votre écoute,
je voudrais dire merci.
(Applaudissements)